[Music]
and my dad knows submitted by lip doodle
I think me a limp noodle oh you're so
close man
a state lawmaker handed out meeting
notes that contain a screenshot with
porn tabs open past oh oh so [ __ ]
funny I think that is completely okay
everybody needs to jack off especially
lawmakers cuz it's a very high-stress
job fighting he [ __ ] up by looking at
porn all on a government computer that's
true - and also - what type of porn was
it is it weird porn is just normal for
sure yeah is it like man [ __ ] octopus
I'm surprised he could even go on portal
on his government computer purchases his
laptop oh it's so impersonal yeah so
these are have restricted site accesses
I bet you TIFF knows all the details I
do okay okay trust people wearing blue
all right so this states representative
for the state of Rhode Island his name
is Ramon Bettis pinch it along he might
not be Mexican oh he's Puerto Rican
Cubano pottery Cano he was testifying on
an automobile crash protection bill so
he brought these printouts or these
handouts to hand out to these people to
see like information that supports his
bill and so and one of these in the
handouts there was a screenshot of an
entire laptop screen and you can see the
point out so before there's multiple
tabs come on that's the right way to
view porn rows hey I gotta give it to
him though he was responsible in the
midst of [ __ ] jacking off he's like
cool God get back to work
my head's right now my head's right
let's do it he's a Democrat with a red
tie no that's the that's the enemy's
colors we did it their blood and Crips
yeah it is like Bloods and Crips
Democrats are Bloods and the Republicans
are Bloods
maybe he's secret
Democrats are Crips and I want to saying
that he did it look at the handouts that
he received and so he's claiming that he
received these notes from us a person
like his friend that was helping him on
this my friends been jacking off not me
he didn't realize it until he started
getting phone calls of these people I
received it like hey like do you see
what's on your handout and so that's
when he posted this on Facebook would
you like to read which I don't even know
how he's a politician writing like this
oh my god people what you see wrong in
this picture I was sending this picture
with information I need it for one of my
bill I didn't notice what was wrong with
it until I got a few calls about it my
fault for noticing that that the picture
I had received has something bad on it
and use it by mistake sorry to everyone
this is my stem end speak English
I guess handout that was okay its Puerto
Rican so up here they blurred it up but
it says team something team something
and then something young cute brunette
she's just studying the [ __ ] what's
hip these days I think you're just
starting like teen driving statistics
they blurt out the porn site that's okay
though man [ __ ] whatever gender mobile
maybe at the end of the day bro you got
a whack [ __ ] off man and we want our
politicians to have a clear mind and if
you got semen backed up in those balls
you cannot make good policy choices I
sure I'll give you that thing is he's a
[ __ ] sloppy-ass Republican that
doesn't do the [ __ ] or never convert
whatever he is democratic politician
look at his [ __ ] statement a bunch of
[ __ ] typos and then he's just a
sloppy worker that's all he should say
on a better cleaner screenshot like
[ __ ] crop that [ __ ] that's true I
agree with that too
but that's where he's from though and
they're from Rhode Island he's suck No
when you go to like big cities like when
you go to a big city like if death will
try to run against the LA mayor the LA
men would smash them they're just way
too
way more sophisticated come on I'm
serious but they have Ivy League and
Rhode Island like brown and like that's
when you know people aren't very smart
they're yeah and so anyways so um he was
pleading for forgiveness pleading for
forgiveness why if he said there's
nothing wrong since the story has been
out like if there's a new stuff that no
a-hunting stemming what's his new cement
he was on the House floor and he was
just insisting that he was not the one
who opened those porn tabs and so he
said I'm not gonna tell you about my
friend did it it wasn't me this house
alike or representatives yeah like that
House of Representatives was on the
floor crying or something sorry that
quote I am NOT a pervert I made a big
mistake of trusting too much in people
no one said you were a pervert
I hate politicians these days I know
people in here don't believe me they say
that's the excuse everybody makes but I
think it is a possibility because I
don't check that stupid page that's the
reason this is what he should have done
one either come clean and blame the
people that was blaming him this is one
scenario or to rap the [ __ ] out if
someone did do this hey
this was my son's research I put him on
this [ __ ] [ __ ] and his dumb ass was
jacking off and sent all this stuff and
then have your son publicly apologize
and say yeah sorry I'm sorry I I made my
daddy look stupid all right that's one
option the second one is all the people
that are talking [ __ ] to you they're
probably your opposing members or
they're probably someone that you know
get dirt on them and when you go on in
front of the house be like look [ __ ]
Jerry put the finger Jerry of Michigan
Democrat check this out you want to
[ __ ] put me on the on the
[ __ ] cross well you know what I
know for a fact that you like getting
tickled in the ball sack by hookers
every Friday night and here are some
pictures beau how about you [ __ ]
yeah how about you Rhonda rip
blood kin from [ __ ] New York
how about you I know you go to the
bathhouse and cheat all the time on your
husband
which a [ __ ] mistress plot
which is a lesbian that's what you do
nobody here is clean as God said cast
the first tone for he who has no sin I'd
lead you to cast the first tone he
without sin cast the first stone [ __ ]
huh BAM so now we got that in order
let's get back down to the Puerto Rican
car accident I'm sure you did it because
it's really tiny but it was cream shot
it at 2:07 a.m. that's the perfect
jacking off right but he can't go to
sleep so he's like oh he's not gonna
mention that person his name cuz he's
like ultimately it's my fault because I
did it dude just say see if you were
just honest it wouldn't be a part you
can't be honest these people being
honest is not being honest he needs to
rat him out but what a little [ __ ] well
what is like the person who's
screenshotted it for him is somebody
that's very important like maybe he
could be a sponsor or somebody who's
backing him up or he's Obama himself I
guarantee you he is not being honest man
he she just came out and said listen man
my wife won't [ __ ] me anymore all I
gotta do is jack off at night cuz it
makes me go to sleep
that's the politician I want but I still
care about public policy say doing two
things at once if Trump can be our
president he could say that in a public
school you know what I forgot about that
how do you think Trump became a [ __ ]
president is because nobody wanted to be
real with their words like the way he is
Hillary was dodging and [ __ ] like come
on Hillary if you just came out and said
hey check it out me or him this guy's a
[ __ ] you know what I yeah I did some
corrupt [ __ ] who didn't do some corrupt
[ __ ] but I'll make this [ __ ]
country run I'll be like oh you know
I wonder what you're probably gonna take
away my guns you [ __ ] [ __ ] but I
like you now
but now she's too much of a robot dude
that's what happened I don't think any
adult out there would hate somebody else
for watching a little porn yeah they
would there's a bunch of hypocritical
[ __ ] them but I'm saying [ __ ] them [ __ ]
damn you [ __ ] me non jacking ass
[ __ ]
they are jacking that's the probably so
admit there's like 90% of the people
lying ass [ __ ]
the statistics show that like 70 percent
of Internet storage spaces are used for
porn and a lot of the browsing is who's
doing all that searching huh is this
what you hear it's not the Quakers cuz
they ain't got no internet no girls -
they're like how do I love my boyfriend
you know my boyfriend thinks that porn
is so disgusting I guarantee you he's
the one that's jacking off the most of
the real [ __ ] if but guy has to
volunteer terribly say hey babe you know
me those guys don't [ __ ] watch porn
that means you know you said you don't
watch porn I don't watch a point as much
anymore as what I said no but I said
though I don't watch porn as much as I
used to because it's too accessible so
when I was younger it was different cuz
we had to get it from the hall means we
had to get some other [ __ ] so when we
watched it was more of a tree now it's
just there and they don't have porn
stars like they used to huh
everybody's a porn star not I remember
those days yeah back in the day while we
were watching porn it was super [ __ ]
exciting now when you watch it it's kind
of like it's just too accessible you
could type in pie and [ __ ] will pop up
it's like yeah what's the point of you
know cuz you look for pie and never stop
doing the same move so that's what I
said I said I watch porn ever I just
it's not as fun as it used to be I hope
you guys enjoy this video for more
please subscribe to our Channel and you
can check out the last video right here
[Music]